[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
we're
yeah
in the street there's nothing
left to eat we're on our
winning streak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody tonight we're debating
whether or not there is code within dna
and we are starting
right now
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thrilled to have
you here for another epic debate
this is going to be a fun one folks and
want to let you know if it's your first
time here at modern day debate i'm your
host james coons and we're a
neutral platform attempting to let
everybody have
their shot at making their case on a
level playing field
and so if you are sick in the head like
us and you like
juicy controversial debates consider
hitting that subscribe button as we have
many more to come for example you'll see
at the bottom right of your screen
matt dillahunty and dr josh bowen will
be in a tag team debate
coming up this month on the topic of
biblical slavery
and that'll be against the father-son
duo
of stuart and cliff nettle so that
should be a blast
hope to see you there folks and want to
let you know a few things
for this channel before we get rolling
into the actual debate first if you
haven't seen we're on podcast
so if you want to listen to modern day
debate on the go well hey what are you
waiting for
see if you can find us on your favorite
podcast app if you can't find us
i mean we're on almost all of them folks
but if you can't let me know we will
work to get
modern day debate on that podcast app
and
last before we get into the
introductions for the speakers
want to let you know folks the format's
going to be pretty easy going tonight
pretty much our standard about 15
minutes and that's flexible so if they
need as much as 20 or as
few as two they can but we'll have those
opening statements
starting with john then we'll have tom's
opening statement as well and then
conversation for about 60 minutes
followed by about 30 minutes of q
a so if you happen to have a question
feel free to fire it into the old live
chat
if you tag me with modern day debate it
makes it a lot easier for me to see it
and get that question into the list so
with that
i'm going to introduce our speakers
we're thrilled to have them folks this
is going to be a lot of fun
and so if you have not heard of the
youtube channel
stated clearly oh my gosh you're in for
a treat folks so let me first introduce
john who is the leader of stated clearly
and so first
john perry is a science educator and the
founder of stated clearly
a website and youtube channel producing
animations about genetics and evolution
stated clearly animations have been
viewed millions
of times and are used in classrooms and
museums around the world
he began the project in 2012 with his
first animation
quote what is dna and how does it work
so
thrilled to have you john thanks so much
for being with us
yeah yeah it's good to be here
absolutely and
tom jump back again glad to see you as
well tom jump letting you guys
know folks tom jump has debated
professional philosophers ranging from
for example
dr randall rouser and also has been on
the side of
speakers such as matt villahunty in the
past and so we're thrilled to have
tom who's a youtube regular debater on
his own channel as well as oftentimes
here we're glad to have him back
and he is linked in the description as
well so you can find
all of the links of both speakers in the
description folks
what are you waiting for they're waiting
for you right now and so with that
we are going to jump into it so we're
going to hand it right over to john for
his opening statement
want to say thank you gentlemen again
for being here and john thanks so much
the floor is all yours
cool great let me share my screen with
everybody here
so i've got some slides
the just just to kind of you know show
you what
what i'm up to what i do i do speaking
events
but mostly what i do is i create
teaching materials for use in the
classroom
and so i've got a youtube channel stated
clearly and i've also got a website
statedclearly.com where those animations
can be found and they're used in
high school and sometimes college
classrooms
for you know introductions to genetics
evolution
and chemistry and then i've got a second
channel stated casually where i do
lectures and so over there i've got one
on signaling theory
which is how it is that communication
systems
encoding decoding systems like we're
going to learn about today actually
evolve naturally
this is a really well studied area of
research
signaling theory and i've got a whole
lecture over there that talks about that
i'm not sure if we're going to get much
into the origin
of the genetic code but uh we will be
talking about you know
that the genetic code really is an
encoding system
uh i've worked recently with the center
for chemical evolution i've been doing
animations with them every year
they are researching the origin of life
they haven't focused a whole lot on the
origin of the genetic code that's kind
of
like later on in the development of life
than what they were researching but
geneticists and people in origin of life
chemistry they all consider the genetic
code to be
code because it allows us well because
it really does act like code as we'll
see today but
it also allows us to use information
theory all the mathematics from
computing
to analyze the genetic code and
that's important in biology
so the question today really that that
that i want to be talking about is does
the genetic code work like
character or control encoding in machine
language so the zeros and ones in a
computer
are are nucleotides inside of codons do
they
behave in a similar way and the best way
to
do this is to just explain briefly how
the genetic code works
and briefly how computer code works and
really i mean
i guess the audience will decide whether
or not they're similar or not
but in molecular genetics there are two
main types
of genes you've got rna template genes
that do not use the genetic code
they simply are templates for functional
chains of rna
so the ribosome for example which is a
major
important uh molecule in our bodies in
our cells
it's mostly made of rna and so there are
genes that are just templates for it
so in dna there's a template for an rna
that ends up becoming the ribosome and
then you have protein coding genes and
these
genes actually make use of the genetic
code this thing
that we call the genetic code which is
right here
now when people talk about when people
say that there's code
in dna or the dna has a language
they're almost always talking about this
thing right here the genetic code
this on the left i have the the classic
chart
that contains the genetic code that
you'd see in a textbook
and on the right i've just drawn the
same thing or outlined the same thing
vertically so we can easily compare it
to multiple different other types of
code
later on in this this presentation so
on the left is what you typically see in
a book on the right is what
you'll be seeing a lot in this
discussion here we have machine code
this is ascii
modern computers use
oh these most of them use a variation of
this they don't still use ascii
but this was used you know back in the
in the 60s when the genetic code was
first decoded this is what a lot of
people were using
in their computers and again it's just a
slight variation of this it's used now
but you have uh a series of
of letters uh if you're if you've got a
typewriter for example
so a b c d that are encoded into zeros
and ones that the machine can understand
and then you also have controls like
delete which are
uh encoded in a way the machine can
understand in ones in this case
so here's the genetic code side by side
with ascii
now the the functional bits inside of a
cell
are mostly made of protein here i've got
a little cartoon of hemoglobin
and each little glob inside the
hemoglobin is an amino acid
and the protein is this is a
three-dimensional structure
made out of amino acids and so you've
got a bunch of different amino acids
there's 20 of them in humans
and they're stuck together head to tail
into chains which fold up into
three-dimensional shapes
and those three-dimensional shapes are
the proteins and according to the
different shape that that protein
happens to have it's going to have a
different function
hemoglobin's function is to grab onto
oxygen
molecules and release those when blood
go
when the blood cell that's carrying the
hemoglobin passes nearby
oxygen starved tissue but there's lots
there's thousands of types of proteins
and they have they're all shaped
differently because they're made out of
different amino acids their sequence of
amino acids is different
they've folded up into different
three-dimensional shapes and those
shapes determine their function the
amino acids that i've drawn here is
these little colored
squiggly balls and stuff they're
actually molecules
so here is aspartic acid aspartic acid
is one of the
20 amino acids that we use in our bodies
and
you can see here the oxygen atoms are
red carbon
is gray uh hydrogen is white and so on
so they're just
they're just molecules and in the
genetic code
the little the three letter uh with the
lower case the little abbreviated things
those are just abbreviations for the
name of each amino acid
so aspartic acid is asp in the genetic
code
but that's all it's representing so
in your body amino acids make up
proteins proteins make up cells cells
make up tissues tissues make up organs
and
that makes up you so the
dna does a lot of different things but
one of its most important functions
is to tell ribosomes how to build
specific proteins
inside the cell and so you've got your
dna in the nucleus of the cell
and it's made out of nucleotides there's
four different types of dna nucleotides
thymine cytosine adenine and guanine
guanine
and then there are enzymes that
so that's where the genetic information
is stored it's in dna they don't
actually have little letters on them
obviously they're just molecules
but inside the nucleus is where the dna
is stored
and it can't really do much in there
it's it's stored
in there and little enzymes run along
the dna and make copies of it
they make messenger rna strands strange
strands of single-sided rna
which is a molecule very similar to dna
and
that has uh mostly the same uh
bases in it it's got uracil in there
which is different than dna
but that goes out into the uh cytoplasm
of the cell
where it eventually meets up with a
ribosome but
what i want to drive home here is that
these these nucleotides they are also
just
molecules so amino acids are molecules
the nucleotides are also molecules
every three nucleotides makes what we
call a codon
and so here we have a ggg
codon and it's a guanine guanine guanine
so if i if i show you the actual 3d
molecules here
that's what it would look like that's
what that codon looks like but the whole
chain
is split up into chunks of three that
the ribosome can read
so a chain of rna goes out of the
nucleus into the mouth of a ribosome
which clamps down on it and it reads it
three nucleotides at a time so
one codon at a time and it uses that to
build
the protein chain which then folds up
into its three-dimensional shape
and every three letters every three
nucleotides in the chain of rna
those act as a symbol for a specific
amino acid
so it tells the ribosome grab this
specific amino acid out of solution and
add it to the growing chain
and you know physically what's happening
there is a transfer rna is attracted
it's got an anticodon and it's attracted
to the codon
and so on but essentially what's
happening is the ribosome
is getting instructions from the rna
telling it how to build
a protein what type of amino acid should
it add to the growing chain
next and the the tape the rna tape it
goes through
the ribosome it moves through it and
every time
three new nucleotides are hit the
uh the ribosome grabs another amino acid
and that's how this process works
so you know i said that uh
the codon is a symbol for an amino acid
you know the cambridge dictionary a si a
symbol is a sine shape or
object that is used to represent
something else it's very important to
realize here that the
the nucleotides the codons are not
turned into amino acids they represent
amino acids
the ribosome and the trnas that work
with the ribosome
are structured in such a way that they
read
the rna and they treat each codon as a
symbol
that tells the ribosome which amino acid
to grab next
so the the codons represent they do not
become they
represent amino acids and they've been
assigned
specific meanings over the course of
evolutionary history
that's they're not there's nothing in
physics that says that ggg has to
code for uh uh
glycine as in as is the case here so
here we've got the the uh
the codon is a symbol for glycine
it is not glycine it is not transformed
into glycine it is a symbol for glycine
that the ribosome uses to you know
build protein and there are different
here this chart here i'm showing you the
standard genetic code this is the one
that our
nuclear genes use but they're actually
different
versions of the genetic code it where
different assignments have been made
so different codons the codons will will
be assigned to a different
amino acid or they'll be assigned to a
start or a stop
function for the ribosome to obey but
there's
you know so there's multiple different
types of genetic code
these symbols had to be assigned and
they were assigned
by the process of evolution in the
ancient ancient past
so how does computer code work now we
know how
the genetic code works but first are
there any questions
like technical questions on anything
that i showed there with
the genetic code that maybe that you
would have tom
uh not yet no okay
so here i have some human-made codes
next to the genetic code so we've got
artificial codes next to the natural
code here
and we got morse code and morse code was
kind of it was like the
grandfather of boto code and then ascii
code eventually
boto code and ascii code were both used
in computers and now we use slight
variations of
of ascii code but the
morse code you had you had commands like
start and stop so the start of a message
the end of a message
and then you had uh you know character
codes like
you have dots and dashes to represent a
b and c
and the cool thing about this is you can
send it over a wire through
electric impulses so we could transmit
messages across the ocean boto code
works in a very similar way you've got
zeros and ones or
holes and no holes and then ascii code
is
is the same also zeros and ones uh and
you've got
you've got commands that are represented
by these
coded symbols and you've got uh
in this case letters of the alphabet
that are also represented
so these these symbols
that the the machine can read are called
character
code points or or control code points
so these character code points here
they're they're they're coding for
letters of the alphabet so characters
but you can also have code points that
code for certain controls
so in boto code you've got letter and
figure
so if you're if if you're currently
typing letters and you want to start
or you're currently typing numbers and
you want to start typing letters in your
message
you have to do the letter shift command
which is 0001
and that will make the machine switch to
start typing out letters
instead of numbers and you know ascii
code has its own
controls as well and in the genetic code
you've got stop
and start as different control code
points
so these code points
are uh the symbols that the machine can
read
that represent something that uh
they act as symbols so here in boto code
uh bottle code was used originally on
tape like what we see here
and so i've got an f encoded i'm
pointing to an f
in the code here the little tiny holes
in the middle are not part of the code
those are just
little little little gears would hold on
to those
and move the tape along as the machine
is reading it
but the f is 0
1 1 1 0 or blank spot whole whole whole
blank spot and actual tape and here is
how the machine
would actually work so you're feeding it
by the way this is what
back when the genetic code was
discovered people were using these
this was the standard piece of equipment
if you wanted to type out a memo
multiple times
you would encode that memo in boto code
or an ascii code
which was encoded and physically encoded
into little holes in a piece of paper a
string of paper
and you would feed that through the
machine and it would command
it would tell the the printer how to
print out your memo and so you could
print it as many times as you wanted
and you also had computers that did this
you would write your code
in holes that are punched in paper and
the machine would physically read
that code and this is how the physical
machine physically reads that code just
like a ribosome reads
a chain of rna one codon at a time
here we have this machine physically
reading the code encoded in this piece
of paper
one code point at a time you can see
i've circled there these little metal
pins
push up and those cause different
switches to be switched inside the
machine
and that causes a different key to be uh
pressed
you know with mag electric magnets and
motors and so on
so this one of the one of the things a
lot of people don't get about
the genetic code they think that it
doesn't count as code because
it's working physically there's physical
molecules that are physically
interacting with the physical ribosome
the exact same thing is true
in in machines in a computer today the
the physical parts you've got
transistors
but it's it's a little bit less
intuitive when you look at a modern
computer
but it really is a physical machine
that's physically reading the commands
i mean things are not magically encoded
these are
the zeros and ones are physical switches
either switched on and off inside of a
computer these these
transistors so
this is how this is how the code works
and if we look at the genetic code
versus
boto code here we've got code points
the code point in the genetic code is a
codon and the code point in boto code is
you know a series of holes and
but they're both code points it
functions the same way
and life as it does in our
contraptions it's a really fascinating
aspect
of biology but
just to just to end this here
richard dawkins pointed this out in
the river out of eden his his book
he says the machine code of the gene is
uncannily computer-like
apart from differences in jargon the
pages of molecular biology journal might
be interchanged with those of a computer
engineering journal
so that's my opening statement here
i would say that the genetic code really
does function
in a way that's important similar
in all the important ways to the code
that we now used
in computers for character encoding and
command encoding so
excellent thank you very much john
appreciate it
and with that folks we are excited to
jump
we are excited to jump into tom's
opening statement as well so
we'll flip it over to tom thanks so much
for being here tom the floor is all
yours
awesome so when we ask the question as
dna code we have to clarify what we mean
by code because code is poly cms there's
multiple usages of the word code
in the technical academic literature
code is just a
simple kind of a pattern that is shannon
information kind of a pattern so any
physical thing can have a code in it no
problem
but when many people use the term code
they mean there's some kind of
arbitrary construction an abstract
meaning hidden in the word so like if
you look at the word tree
you can't determine what the word tree
means just by looking at the physical
parts like there's nothing
in the stripe of the word that
determines what it means it's just it's
completely arbitrary
we've we've determined that this shape
weight means this thing and that's kind
of
how we got it so there's an abstract
component
to the word which makes it a human code
and so there's a distinction between a
human code which has these
abstract arbitrary properties to it and
a physical code which is
purely determined by the physical
constants of the shape of the thing
uh and so when we're talking about is
dna a code
which one of these is it more like is it
more like the human code which is
abstract and arbitrary and we can make
it whatever we want
or is it more like a physically
determined system like a key
in a keyhole or magnets attaching in a
specific order
and it seems clear to me that from the
presentation the dna is much more like
the physical code
like a key and a keyhole or magnets
connecting in a certain pattern way or
patterns in a crystal it's not like a
human abstract code where there's some
abstract meaning hidden inside of it you
need some kind of a mind
to impart this meaning on it no it's
it's determined by the physical
processes as
uh as he said so when i say g a does not
have a code i'm specifically referring
to those
abstract arbitrary things that seem to
require a mind to get
so i would agree with everything in a
statement absolutely it does have the
technical code as
demonstrated in the biological
literature but it doesn't have anything
abstract or arbitrary
that's that's the one claim i want to
make in my position
so like in uh the stanford encyclopedia
the
there's a quote that i like to read from
that about this which is the arguments
in godfrey smith and griffiths that that
dna is
like a language is that there is one
kind of information or symmetric
property that genes and only genes have
coding for the amino acid sequences of
protein molecules
but this relation reaches only so far as
the amino acid sequence
it does not vindicate the idea that gene
codes for whole organism phenotypes let
alone
provide a basis for the wholesale use of
information or semantic language
in biology genes can have a reliable
causal role in the production of whole
organism phenotypes of course
but if this causal relation is to be
described in informational terms
then it is a matter of ordinary shannon
information which applies to
environmental factors
so what that basically means is it's
like the key it's a physical determined
system so it's like a
code only so far as the shannon
information sense of just
crystals or also have information in it
it's not
a code like the arbitrary language that
humans make up
we can't just make it anything we want
to make it fit however we desire we
can't make a codon 27 length long
because ribosomes can't read that
so we can't just arbitrarily determine
the start or stop
codes in a codon like we could for a
language like if in windows we can
change the the start code
to anything we want we could take it to
chimichanga we could say chimichanga is
the start code
and just rewrite an entire language
around that you can't do that with dna
because it is physically determined the
physical shape
determines what it can bond with and
what it can't bond with and
what it can represent and can't
represent and so in that sense it is not
a code in the more general sense that
theists use it to mean
where there's some abstract or arbitrary
concept to it and that would be and
that's what i'll conclude
is from there we'll jump right into the
open discussion quick reminder folks our
guests are
linked in the description so you can
hear plenty more from our guests after
this debate
but right now right into the open
discussion thanks guys
all right cool so you're you're talking
about our what do you mean by arbitrary
when you when you say that a code has to
be arbitrary uh we can make it anything
we want we can replace it with anything
we want
yeah so in a genetic code the codon
assignment actually is arbitrary
and you have different you have
different organisms that have us have
different assignments to the
uh code from codon to amino acid and we
can actually make them artificially as
well we've
scientists have artificially made new
codons and
there's so there's a question as to
whether or not
the codons that we use because you could
have
millions of variations of the genetic
code but we only have something like 30
that we've discovered so far
so pretty much all organisms are using
the same genetic code mostly the same
genetic code
and the question is why is that a frozen
accident is
just one was selected and then all of
all organisms have inherited that
or is there something about the genetic
code that is
optimized for some sort of a function
you know and morse code
e is this the the smallest symbol in
morse code it's just one dot
no dash is just one dot and that's
that's been optimized because it's
most common letter yeah it's the most
common letter
so but it's it's arbitrarily assigned
but it's also been optimized for
something
so we know that the genetic code is is
arbitrarily assigned because you could
have assigned one of million
nature could have assigned millions of
different codes to it
but one of the questions that origin of
life chemists have is
is it optimized for some sort of a
function or not is it
better at coding for proteins and
alternative
versions would be and that's still kind
of up in the air
but it certainly is arbitrary i mean you
can
like i said you can edit it you can you
can actually change it you can add new
codons
uh you can change code on assignments
and some organisms have already done
that
just within their own system can you
make a code on this eight long
uh you'd have to significantly engineer
you'd have to change the the structure
of the ribosome
but just you'd have to change the
structure of a computer to change the uh
um how you know how big of a how big a
byte is you just
also have to change the structure of a
computer so no one's ever tried that but
it theoretically it's just as possible
as it would be in a computer
yeah i don't have to change anything in
a computer to change make it an 87
letter long start program it's just you
just make it 87 letters and say if you
see this then start
so there's a physical change required
it's just already there
you're not changing the byte size though
you're you're just adding more bytes
so the in the genetic code you could add
more bytes but you
to change the byte size a byte is three
codons
i guess that would be six bytes if you
were to convert it to binary
i think but the um yeah you
like you know you buy you buy it you buy
hardware that's either like a
what is it i don't know what the what
the byte
systems are but they're that's
that's that depends on the machine that
you're running and so yeah you'd have to
edit the
the function you'd have to edit the
machine to change the start code on
so the physical shape of your ribosome
prevents you from you making anything
more than a three letter currently you
have to make a completely new ribosome
right
just like the physical setup of your
machine in a computer
determines how big a byte is yes
yeah but i didn't say anything about
bytes i can make the start code whatever
i want
by adding more by adding more character
but by adding more
um yeah by by adding more bits to it you
could
but not not by changing the bite size
yeah i didn't say anything about the
bite size so
in one of your examples was the start
and stop codons there's a codon that
functions as the start or stop so i can
make the start or stop
code whatever i want of any length i
want bite size doesn't really make a
difference
to the start or stop code that's just
whatever it's reading well there are
some organisms that require
a longer or shorter
series of nucleotides before the start
codon otherwise it won't recognize it
so actually there are there are variable
length
um start commands in in biology yes
so like in eukaryotes i believe
eukaryotes
need a big a longer starting sequence
than um than you than bacteria do
so there is variation in that yeah from
organism to organism
it's not so much how the ribosome reads
it it's how the ribosome attaches so the
ribosome has to
actually attach to the messenger rna and
one way to get around um viruses for
example
so let's say that you're you're being
attacked by a lot of viruses as you
could change
and organisms have done this over
evolutionary time they changed the
length
of the uh
the the number of nucleotides that you
need at the start of a message
so that yeah you have changes in length
of start
uh in in biology that that is something
that happens
okay so uh how does the ribosome read
the
uh codons you have transfer
rnas which are bits of rna that are
folded up
into three-dimensional structures and
they have an anti-codon sticking out of
them
and that anti-codon just like just like
we saw that the computer has to
physically read
the code by sticking little prongs into
it
you have the ribosome physically reads
the code
by opening up in a way that
a specific anticodon can come in and
stick to the codon
in the chain of rna and that
trna that has the anticodon also carries
a specific
amino acid and the ribosome will then
rip that amino acid off
and add it to the growing chain so if a
different amino acid hits it it just
won't be able to bond because it's just
not the right shape
right just like just like when the tape
goes through the
the computer the the
triggers that are physically switched
because a computer is a physical machine
it physically works in the physical
world
these physical switches are switched on
and off
just like in the ribosome you have these
physical connections that are made or
not made
it works exactly it i mean you've got
you've got different molecules involved
you've got different specific parts but
in principle it works exactly the same
so it's like a magnet or a key it's a
physical attachment and there's no
abstract anything
to it at all right yeah there's no
abstract anything in the computer either
it's all mechanical yes right so it
wouldn't be a code in the abstract sense
like a human code that we just invent
out of nothing
it's a physically determined system so
the code for
essentially any windows or
computer-based code
is something we made up purely in our
heads and then we make a physical system
to represent that code
but the code itself isn't a physical
system the code itself is something we
made up it's abstract
the code in dna isn't there's no
abstract parts to it it's literally just
the physical system is the code
and that i think is the difference
between a human code
and a physical code so that's why dna is
more akin to a key or a magnet
not a human language based code so just
comparing it to a computer isn't quite
accurate because
the code isn't the computer the code is
something we made up
independent of the computer and we
didn't build a computer around it
but the code and the computer are
separate things
so i think you're confused because if
you
if you want to play a game on a nintendo
for example we we agree that nintendo
uses code right
sure you take a physical disk
or whatever you call those and you
physically insert it into a physical
machine and then you physically touch
physical buttons on a physical
joystick which send physical electric
pulses through a physical wire
there's nothing like the fact that like
everything is like code is physically
encoded into machines
it's being physically used right but if
we got rid of all the machines
we would still have the code because it
was invented by a person
like just do you think simple codes like
the you're saying you'd have it in their
head or something
yeah it's it's something we made up we
literally made it up out of nothing
before we built the physical system to
represent the code so just like the
codes you listed earlier
those weren't like those aren't
instantiated in the physical system
first we made them up we just we
completely just made them up we said
these symbols represent this and
all right yeah evolution did the same
thing evolution said this symbol
represents this in this system it said
that how did it say that
you know that i'm you know that
evolution doesn't talk exactly
exactly the meaning the meaning for
symbols
is an evolved this evolved over
evolutionary time
so these symbols mean nothing outside
the ribosome outside
the genetic encoding system these
symbols mean nothing
their meaning only exists within the
communication system that evolved
between ribosomes and genes this is
a communication system that evolved over
gradual time
and the study of this is in um
information or sorry in uh signaling
theory
is how we study how how do you get
signals how do you get the evolution of
symbols so that the
sender and the receiver
are able to use symbols to communicate
with one another and this happened
at the origin of life well at the origin
of
protein coding life in
in the ancient past yeah i mean i
totally agree with that but that means
that there's no abstract thing there it
wasn't just a an
arbitrary abstract code we just made up
there's a i'm telling you it's
absolutely arbitrary it is completely
arbitrary
we've gone over this different organisms
use different codes
it's not there's nothing in physics that
says this codon must represent this
amino acid
that that only exists in the system once
it's physically built
once it physically exists just like in a
computer
a computer is a physical thing it's an
actual machine that physically
reads okay so there's no abstract things
there so my point is still correct
no abstract nothing abstract in it at
all what do you mean by abstract tell me
uh abstract versus concrete objects um
abstract meaning it doesn't have a
physical correlate it's just a made-up
category so do you think that a computer
has abstract
things inside of it it's made out of
abstract things no do you think that
your brain has abstract things in it
no abstract means non-physical yeah so
an idea in your head is also
i mean we're getting to the point to
where we can actually physically read
uh ideas in people's heads i agree
yeah there's there's no significant
difference
i think it what's important here is is
to get to why
what i've noticed is that over probably
like the past five years
uh atheists which by the way i am an
atheist
i've just to make sure people don't get
confused here i put
i put a little ode to darwin behind me
here
so the what i've been noticing every
time i post a video about
genetics if it ever says the genetic
code in it
i'll get creationists they'll send me
notes that say the
the genetic code is a code all codes
have a coder
therefore the genetic code required a
coder
and then i see atheists attack them and
say no the genetic code isn't a code
it's only some
it's only like a code and
they're attacking the wrong part of that
argument
the the bad part of their argument is
their claim that all codes have a coder
biology is filled with systems of
encoding and decoding
you have the the colors of a flower they
are symbols
that represent i have pollen and i have
sugar
come get it and insects that pollinate
understand that and so an insect will
see that signal from
you know a long ways away and go to that
there's nothing
about that color that's that color is a
genuine
symbol it's it represents sugar it is
not sugar
it represents the sugar this is just one
of many
coding encoding systems that have
evolved naturally nature is filled with
these
and we understand how they evolve there
are lots of aspects of the genetic code
that we don't understand
aspects of the origin of the ribosome
for example that we don't understand but
we do know how
these coding systems evolve and
if you were to try and argue with a
creationist and say no it's not really
code it's just like a code because
of abstract ideas they're going to know
that you're
just trying to evade the the actual
question which is
how on earth were these codons assigned
their specific amino acids how did that
assignment take place
that assignment is uh
it's mysterious to people who don't know
much about how this process works
and it's actually still in large part
mysterious to actual scientists that are
studying the origin of the genetic code
we don't know
exactly how those assignments were made
we do know in general how assignments
are made
because we study this we've studied this
in lots of other systems aside from the
genetic code
so we know how simple assignments are
made in nature
new organisms that are to cooperate
a lot of times they'll end up developing
symbols
and they'll they'll develop means but we
haven't worked it out
fully code okay are there
codes in non-organic systems
my audio cutting out here again yeah a
little bit
testing testing are you better now can
you hear
are you testing testing one two three
four testing testing can you hear better
now
we did have this just before we went
live folks
and we'll wait for john to reconnect do
want to remind you that they're both
linked in the description john
and tom have their
when we were testing i'm gonna have to
reboot so i'm gonna have to call back in
here
no problem we'll do it we'll take just a
minute but you can
get questions while i'm doing that you
got it thanks john
and as mentioned folks we are very
excited
as if you have not heard cosmic skeptic
will be on modern day debate that's
going to be very exciting so
do want to let you know about that you
don't want to miss it that's coming up
on the 16th
and so john will be back in just a
moment going to plug
just a couple of events coming up as we
are really excited about these folks
so that will be on the 16th on whether
or not
veganism is morally obligatory in other
words are you
is it the case that you ought to be a
vegan otherwise you're
you could say morally behind and also
very excited though we have another
show coming up in the future that we're
pumped about this one i don't think i
had shared about yet
on it shared on air but now we finally
have the thumbnail and look at that
thumbnail
isn't it beautiful it's a terrific
tremendous thumbnail you guys we are so
excited at the bottom right of your
screen
you are seeing a thumbnail for you
guessed it i don't know if you guys know
who dr
jeffrey meldrum is i was watching a
documentary on amazon
and it was a good documentary you know
it's like it was a bigfoot documentary
but it was good
so it had 4.5 stars i couldn't help
myself
and i i listened to dr jeffrey meldrum
and i said that guy's articulate i was
like
we should try to get him on the show and
so i reached out to him he's at idaho
state university
he will be on the show that will be on
if i recall right it's on a
saturday it's close to 10 days yep it's
the 23rd so 10 days from today
so if you think that might be a fun one
if you're like me and i can't i gotta
say it folks that's one of them what's
the topic of that one
huh what's the topic for that one
whether or not bigfoot is real
and dr jeffrey meldrum will also by the
way so he's been on like animal planet
he's uh he's pretty popular guy when i
mentioned him in the chat before i even
made the thumbnail
people like several people in the chat
were like i know that is and
erica erica got sick gibbon
actually said that she had emailed him
before with questions about because you
know that's her
well not bigfoot but hominids uh is like
one of her
specialties that she's a grad student
for so she had contacted him
and basically to ask a question about
phd
programs in their you could say shared
domain in the academic world and so yeah
that will be a really fun one folks
and so also though
tom can i tell him the news about this
huge one coming up with you and samuel
sure thank you okay so uh
february 3rd folks finally the first
time in a long time
we're going to have a debate in person
now i'm still trying to figure out if
there's a way i can like
uh make my schedule work to be able to
fly to be there as well as the moderator
or at least a kind of like uh
what day did you say that was huh what
day
february 5th right okay
oh you're yes february 5th it is and so
you guys that's going to be epic that
thumbnail will be up shortly
and so that will be a really fun one if
you remember samuel nassan he was a
co-moderator
for the debate where we hosted dr bart
ehrman
and jonathan sheffield so that's samuel
if you forgot but he's also been on here
he's debated he debated
apologia a long time ago and so
glad to have you back john yeah i'm back
what'd i miss
can you hear everything fine is audio
good now yeah
all right cool so picking up where i
left off are there codes in non-organic
systems
and non-organic systems yeah
so far as we know this this can these
things can only evolve
so you can you can have them you can
have coding systems be invented through
the process of evolution
or through the process of you know
humans
coming up with ideas so are there is
there a code in particle systems like
the elementary table
no why not what's how do you define a
code here
okay i already showed you what a code is
a code has symbols that represent
other as symbol which represents
something that it is not
so in the in the periodic table all you
have is elements
oh if that's a list of elements there's
no encoding and decoding happening in
there
a symbol that represents something it's
not
right a codon is a symbol that
represents an amino acid it is not an
amino acid
it represents an amino acid to the
ribosome
the ribosome interprets it as oh i need
to grab this amino acid and it does
and it does that it's it's physical but
again same within your computer
everything is physical inside of your
computer so if a triangle
could bond with a chevron which then
bonded with a star and it could only
occur in that order would that be a code
no why not the triangle represents the
chevron or the star because it can only
bond if there's a
the triangle then the chevron and the
star
i showed you what the code is um it's
very obvious you've got it you have the
ribosome
it interprets a specific codon
as an amino acid it interprets it as
that
it does not transform it into it it
interprets it as that
right that's the same as what i said so
what it said it reads a thing it sees it
and then because of the shape of the
ribosome it then attaches to a different
thing
so so if you have a triangle and then
you have a chevron that reads the
triangle by attaching it to it
and because of the shape it can only
attach to a star that's the same thing
right
okay so you're saying that it can only
attach to the star when it's attached to
the triangle
yes that would be that would be a signal
so we have
in in that's how the the signaling
system in our hormones
work in a similar way you've got a
protein
that is only reactive when it's bound to
a specific
signaling molecule and that can evolve
when you have two entities under
selection pressure to cooperate
so yeah that we we have a similar system
like that
and how is that different from ice
crystals
and what way well ice crystals ice can't
form in a perfectly
like uh perfectly clear water it has to
have a deformity in it the deformity
comes in and then the deformity
represents the ice
so so the water transfers to the
deformity which then
because of the shape can form it into
ice how is that not
exactly the same thing
that is not causing that's not causing a
specific
um repeatable reaction so you you've got
in in the genetic code so the ribosome
is going to consistently
read the ggg codon as
the uh i think it was a camera which
which amino acid was
as aspartic acid or whatever it was it's
going to consistently read it that way
and consistently build the system or
the the consistently grab that amino
acid out of solution and specifically
only grab that amino acid at a solution
okay so your original definition of code
was a symbol that represents something
that's not
i think the water example provides that
so you're saying there's another part to
the definition
no you're you're
i showed you what the code is i'm not
going to give you a half a sentence
definition of a code i showed you what
the code is i showed you how it
physically works
if you don't understand that then you
need to go back and watch the video
okay i asked what your definition of
code was i don't i don't care about what
you presented
about the genetic code i'm saying what
is your definition of a code okay a
character a character encoding system
like
in in the genetic code is a set of
symbols which represent
another set of either symbols or objects
or commands
that's that's the definition okay how
does my water example not
do exactly that um
it's not it's not commanding the
there's not a set of symbols that are
functioning in your system you're going
to have to explain how those are
different because i'm not seeing the
difference
all right well you don't because
there's a physical shape which is the
the codon and the physical shape then
bonds with something else which has a
different shape
and that different shape than bonds with
something else which has a different
shape
that seems to be the same as the water
example
here we have a whole system where these
are set up to do this
over and over again over and over again
part of your definition and and it
constructs it constructs
like i'm not interested in you trying to
pin me down on weird things with that
with how i
defined it on the spot i showed you how
the code works
and you can watch that and and you can
come up with another
you can come up you can see for yourself
how it's different than the water system
uh well no i can't see it because
they're the same based on your
definition they both qualify as codes
this isn't about pinning you down this
is about you not understanding the the
distinction here being in the argument
like you brought up the
the thing that creationists always come
up in your in your debates and say well
all dna is a code
code requires a code maker therefore
there is a code maker and then the
atheists say
well it's only like a code and then you
criticize the atheists for being wrong
they're when they're not
because it functions exactly like a
computer code in principle
so so the problem here is that what the
theist means by code isn't the same as
what the technical term of what
code actually means so the kind of
code that's in dna is just a physical
system there's no abstract mind required
at all same
same with the computer there's no brain
instead of computer i agree there's
nothing no brains in the computer
yet but different topics uh so so the
when the atheists are correct when they
say the theist is wrong like no
dna is not a code in the way they mean
code
now it is a code in the technical sense
i agree that i agreed that in the
beginning
but there's a difference between the
definitions there and that's the thing
i'm trying to articulate
like how do you define code is kind of
important to the customers the
creationist is saying that the genetic
code works like computer code they're
100 correct
if they're saying something else then i
don't know i mean i don't know what else
they would be saying
but if they're saying that it it works
in principle the same way that a
computer code works
where you have a set of symbols that
have been assigned to
represent specific things then they are
correct
i mean it really works you you have code
points a codon is a code point all you
have to do is change the jargon slightly
and like dawkins pointed out you could
you could be reading a
a computer science book or a biology
textbook and you wouldn't know the
difference
it it really does function the same way
i didn't say it didn't function the same
way as a computer again the problem
saying is that it's not
abstract and arbitrary combining those
terms if you don't like it it is
arbitrary so i'm going to combine those
if it's not abstract then
my point is correct so you got to
address the abstract one the abstract
language of a computer code as made up
by a human and didn't exist in a
computer
is the part they're comparing it to the
code part they're comparing it to isn't
just the physical functioning of the the
dna and the physical
parts the bites of a computer they're
saying that that system
is completely made up by a mind it's
abstract it doesn't have it's not a
physical thing that's determined there
by the shape
whereas for dna it is it's completely
physical it's completely determined
by the shape and the shapes of the rib
zone and the shapes the codon and the
shapes of the
proteins it's all the shapes just like
the computers all the shapes
so the only creationist i've talked to
about this is perry marshall
and he knows exactly how code works in
the computer so when he's talking about
computer code he's talking about
computer code he's saying that
he perry marshall doesn't understand
that we actually know how
symbols are chosen through evolutionary
history
he he didn't understand that so he
actually wrote a whole book saying that
the genetic code is evidence of god
because he didn't understand signaling
theory like he didn't know that we
already have a
this whole system worked out we know how
symbols
form between um organisms as they're
communicating with each other
and we know that it doesn't require a
brain at all you have organisms without
brains
right that can develop symbols i totally
agree so so the point he was
arguing was like the creationist point
he thinks that this code thing that
we're seeing
it's abstract in some part it requires a
mind to abstract this onto the physical
yeah he thinks that you have to have a
mind to assign
meaning to a symbol that is not the case
you don't need
a mind to assign meaning to a symbol all
you need is two
entities under selection pressure to
cooperate and they will start assigning
meaning to symbols
they don't even need brains yeah i
totally agree i think that's an
excellent way to phrase exactly what my
point was so yeah i totally agree with
what you just said there could you say
it again it was
you don't need a mind to assign meaning
to symbols
correct absolutely 100 agree
okay so that i mean the genetic code
is a naturally evolved code and the
meaning for each codon was assigned
by the process of evolution you have two
molecules under under selection pressure
to cooperate it's the ribosome and the
gene
both of them are after proteins they
they benefit from having proteins
and so eventually you had the evolution
of this communication system this
symbol-based communication system
between these two structures and you get
you get protein coding the details of
how that happened or not worked out
but in principle we know how this works
through signaling theory and we have
actually worked out the details
of many different communication systems
in signaling ethereum
you know between uh various insects and
so on
so symbols can evolve they do not have
to be
there you don't need a brain our brains
all
all what our brains are doing really is
their
there i mean there's a lot of aspects of
the brain that aren't fully understood
but what it appears our brains are doing
is
is really rapid trial and error and
modeling of what we think is going to
happen
uh and trial and error is how the
process of evolution works
so you have um could you talk more about
how uh you don't need a brain to impose
meaning on the symbol could you explain
some more examples of that in a physical
system for us
in a physical system um you've got
so bacteria if you've got bacteria who
that that both produce different enzymes
that can digest different parts of the
same type of food
and because they both excrete different
enzymes they actually benefit by being
near each other
because they can both excrete these
enzymes and the two enzymes together
will digest that
food better than one of them trying to
just digest the food on its own
you now have selection pressure for
these bacteria to be in each other's
presence
at a food source and so
how this would evolve how
what would likely happen here is that
the one of the bacteria would
end up picking up just through through
random evolution of their
their receptor proteins
they would evolve a receptor that can
detect a waste product of one of the
other bacteria
and so we call that q detection and so
it would detect that waste product and
it would swim
towards that waste product so it's got
the food in front of it the food item
might be huge
and then it has it's detecting that oh
my buddy's over there i should go get
nix next to him so we can discrete
enzymes together
so it would it would be picking up on a
q it's waste it's it's buddy's waste
product
and evolution would over time get it to
start swimming towards
that ally so just the process of
evolution here
happening just descent with modification
occurring
and eventually you get this this one
bacteria that can sense the presence of
its ally
and swim towards it and doing that makes
it eat better
and have more offspring so you just have
natural selection working on this the uh
the sender of that of that queue that's
excreting the waste product
is also going to be to uh there's going
to be selection pressure now
because it's benefiting as well from its
body swimming up next to it
there's going to be a selection pressure
for it to increase
its excretion of that waste product and
it actually
there's going to be a point where if it
evolves
um the over production of this waste
product even digesting healthy parts of
itself to turn into that waste product
there's going to be a point where
natural selection will favor that
even though it's slightly damaging to
the organism
and it's going to actively transmit
it's going to go out of its way to
actively transmit what what used to be a
waste product
because it's it benefits by signaling to
its its partner that it hey i'm over
here
and when we have a system that has
in signaling theory when you have both
the sender and receiver
that have evolved to change their
behavior or
learned to change their behavior we say
that the
queue has been transformed into a signal
so that's when we officially consider it
to be a signal
is when both entities are
actively
reacting to these either sending them or
or
responding to them that's when we call
them uh
symbols that's when we call them uh
signals instead of just
mere cues would uh it still apply as a
signal if they started that way if they
were
like uh spontaneous generation came out
as already
uh reacting to this signal would it
still count as a code or would that not
count as a code because it didn't
develop it over time
uh in signaling theory we consider it to
be a signal only if it's uh
if it's either learned or evolved
because of the res the
the response that it invokes
so if they just started that way it
wouldn't even count as a code by your
definition
i mean i don't know how you'd say they
just started that way or how you
determined that you started that way
normally when we come into these systems
we come into them already partially
functioning and we assume that
at one point they didn't exist at all
and you can actually piece
piece together their evolution like i
mean actually almost everybody
communicates with
uh waste products humans we communicate
with
co2 that we're not using you know we we
make sounds out of it
um dogs communicate with urine
so i mean that's that's a really common
way but yeah when we're looking at how
these
these signals evolve usually they come
from
just waste products or parts that happen
to be there already
uh well uh this is just a hypothetical
like uh
the in multiverse theory universes can
pop out of existence or many worlds
hypothesis they can change and split and
so we have just an entire universe pop
into existence
that's like a second away from ours
essentially and so these
uh organisms look like they evolve but
they didn't they just popped into
existence
quantum mechanical stuff in that context
would it not
be a code by that definition because it
didn't technically evolve
i'm not interested in speculating on
something that speculative
all i can tell you is that we do have
communication systems that evolve
where you go from from cues to
symbols through the process of evolution
when you have two entities that are
under
pressure to cooperate you have you can
have the evolution
of symbol-based communication systems
okay well another example would be i
made up a language that could have been
made up
five seconds ago that would still be a
code right if
you made it are you talking to someone
with it are you teaching it someone else
well i could it could just be in my head
it could be klingon i'm talking to it
with
imaginary klingon friends uh i mean in
biology they wouldn't uh
you wouldn't consider it a signal unless
it's being transmitted to something that
can understand it
it's just a thought in your head it's i
guess i guess you're transmitting it to
different parts of your consciousness
so all right right so i mean that's my
point here is that
the technical use of code has some very
specific conditions to it
in the in the academic sense it's not
the same as the code that
theists are kind of describing when
they're all dna as a code code to make a
code
perry marshall the creationist who uses
this argument he wrote a book on it he
understands how code actually works and
he's using it
he's using all the technical jargon
correctly the only thing is
he didn't he doesn't know or he doesn't
accept that codes evolve
so he's he's just blinded to that or
intentionally blinded to that
but as far as as far as uh computer code
he understands uh that
you've got a machine that can either
read this or not read it or misread it
i mean if you take photo code and and
replace it with ascii
in a machine that's designed or that's
built to read ascii
it's going to spit out gibberish so
that's um
what would perry marshall say klingon
that i made up in my head is a code
i don't know he's going to say yes you
can say absolutely yes
any language is going to be a code by
his definition an atheist definition
because they do have these implicit
assumptions about what a code is which
is different
than the academic usages of the code
that's kind of the point
but perry perry would also say that
bacteria are using code when they
communicate with each other
um and he's got a chapter in his book on
uh
signaling and bacteria he just doesn't
apparently he doesn't understand that
these things can evolve but
the
if if you try and make the argument with
someone that it's not
code it's just like code you're being
dismissive
and they know that you're being
dismissive it's really obvious it's a
really bad argument
just instead just talk about how codes
evolve like we
we have this whole branch of science
that talks about how coding systems
evolve
it's signaling theory and it's it's well
worked out it's
this isn't i mean there's there's entire
books on it there's textbooks
on it and it's not well known
uh but instead of dismissing them and
saying oh no it's not really code so
therefore you're dumb just say okay
it's it does function like a computer
code functions
it really does and
actually now we even have um we have ais
that can
create their own encoding and decoding
systems this is what uh
this is what google's uses for their top
encryption they're really really high
like top shelf encryption comes from ais
that are
perpetually inventing new coding systems
with each other
and so they pass your message through an
encoding system that's brand new
and then they delete it and then they do
another one or they modify it
and so there's no way to crack the code
well
theoretically there's ways to crack it
but there's no there's no
legitimate way to actually crack those
codes
so we have um yeah computer code
doesn't have to be invented by a human
mind at all now we can actually just
have computers that invent computer code
so this is um uh the mind
the mind the human mind need not apply
i mean yeah i totally agree with you on
that part but my argument here is that
it's wrong to criticize
the atheist by saying it's not a code
because when they say it's not a code
the comparison isn't the same like
obviously
creationists say that yes it's a code
like computer code
but they're implicitly including all
these other assumptions they have and
what that means that
codes have this abstract meaning that
requires a mind
they have that assumption built into
their definition of code
and if it doesn't have that it's not a
code by definition
and because they're using that
definition is not a code by their
definition because that's
not what a code is there's a difference
between what they think of as a code
and what a code is in the academic
literature
i i've never heard someone say that a
code requires abstract ideas all i've
heard is that
they say that all codes require a coder
and all you can all you have to do is
say no they don't actually there's lots
of codes that don't require coders
there's a bunch of in biology and then
now there's some in computer science
where
the there's no mind there's no there's
no brain encoding them but yeah
you have ai's that can that can create
coding systems
and there's a whole field of biology
called signaling theory so
you don't have to all you have to do is
say
the genetic code is a natural code it's
naturally evolved
it did not require an inventor because
this is what the process of evolution
does it acts as an inventor in place of
an inventor
if you have dissent with modification
plus natural selection
you get the development of these
fantastic well-adapted contraptions you
know that we call organisms
and these even include communication
systems like
we see the flowers communicating with a
pollinator we see that
genes are communicating with ribosomes
this is awesome this is
this is biology this is the power of the
process of evolution it's fascinating
sure another question would you see that
plants have codes
uh where they don't actually read
anything just like the shape of the
seeds falling into the ground or
whatever was that the seed reading the
dirt
um no that's one way like
in in all the signaling systems you have
two participants
if it's one way you call it q detection
so you can have
so the difference between signaling and
and signaling theory the difference
between a code and just um
uh that you you do have encoding and
decoding but then you also just have
uh cue detection and we have this
with brains too it's actually kind of
easier to think about with brains so
when i was in cub scouts
we would we would go camping all the
time in bear territory
and we were told that if you're walking
through the forest far away from camp
you should
be loud because bears will run away if
they hear you
so the bear is an active it's it's
it's searching for cues that people
might be coming and it will run away
before they get there unless it's really
hungry i suppose
but uh black bears which were the bears
that lived in our area they were scared
of humans so
if we were just loud then uh we would
scare the bear away because it's
listening for cues
but if we're actively if we're
if we put bells on our shoes because you
can actually do this too just put
bare bells on your shoes now i'm
actually actively sending a signal i
went from passively
sending out a queue to actively sending
out a signal so now
now we actually have a signaling system
going on i'm warning the bear that i'm
coming
so that's the difference between a queue
and a signal
but you can have rocks can be queues
dirt can be a cue but you've only got
one
actor that's that's actively detecting
those cues
so you don't call it a code or s or
signal you just call it um
there's no symbols involved it's just uh
you've got one entity that's picking up
on a cue
uh in the environment does that make
sense
uh sure so if if god was the only thing
that existed
and god made up a language that wouldn't
count as a code because he's only the
only one
interacting with it right uh
i don't know i'm talking about when you
got two real things
two real things that are really
interacting with each other
um so a bear and a human or just a bear
in some
a cave so a bear is also a cave detector
but the cave is not sending out actively
transmitting signals to the bear hey
come over here come stand me
the bear is a cue detector it's
detecting cues
like when i see this particular shape
that usually means it's a cave so i
should go i should go look at that cave
um so so but like you said earlier if
i'm just talking to myself in my head
that doesn't technically count as a code
because it's not
there's no two participants right well
it might
i think you could probably divide your
mind to different
a lot of times when we think we divide
ourselves into different uh
thing i mean and we do this in software
too you you divide a program into
multiple parts and have them play
against each other
um and they will develop yeah they'll
develop
signaling systems between each other so
i guess you can but
you're dividing it into two entities to
make that argument
uh well right and i would say that
that's where the
distinction the definitions is going to
become obvious is because when you ask
these those questions they're not going
to be able to come up with those
responses they're going to say nope
there is one mind that is a singular
thing of one perfect non-divisible part
in our soul or whatever
and so they're going to have this very
fundamental difference in the use of the
terms which is why i think that
the atheists are kind of right to say
it's not a code in the same sense
because i don't think the theists think
of code in the same way you do
well okay the genetic code
is technically functions the same way as
a computer code does i mean it is a set
of symbols
that have a specific meaning and
they're transmitted linearly you have a
it's even digital i mean you actually
you break it up but you could break up a
codon into
into nucleotides so you've got specific
digits within the code it's very
it's very very very similar oh i agree i
agree that it is very much like a
computer i totally agree i've agreed
with you the whole time through that
part
my only qualm is that with dsu the code
they have those extra assumptions there
and i think
that's the criticism i have of
the way the code is used in that
argument yeah
but again i would just attack that idea
and that idea only the only idea that
they have that's wrong
is that all codes require a coder that's
not the case the process of evolution
can generate a code it does it all the
time
uh and and it's it's well studied this
is it's well documented
if you look at um what is it behavior
any behavioral ecology textbook it'll
have a whole section on how
signaling systems evolved a signaling
system being a symbol-based
communication system
how these things evolve it's very well
understood well you can do a test you
can ask any of them like perry mason
would it still be a code if god's mind
before any humans were made or would it
be a code in a person's mind if there
were no other
parts of their brain or whatever and
they're probably going to come up with a
different answer
to show there is actually a difference
there you just didn't realize it
uh i mean perry's argument is very
he's showing how code works he's showing
how the genetic code works
and then he just makes the mistake of
saying that all codes require a coder
and that's that's the only mistake he's
making that's the only error he's making
well i'd say ask him i'd say ask him
exactly what i just asked you to see if
there's a difference because i'm betting
there's going to be
okay no he might actually end up
watching this
so very interesting this is a great time
to jump into the questions if you guys
are ready for that
i'm ready yeah yeah excellent and so
thank you very much everybody for your
questions
we're going to start with the first one
that came in which is from frank's 9-2
said love this channel james keep it up
bro well thank you
franks seriously means a lot and it's
people like you that make it awesome and
the debaters as well they're the
lifeblood of the channel and we
appreciate them
barry berry thanks for your super
sticker appreciate that
dancing pair uh logical plausible
probable has entered the building he
says epic after show kicks off
five minutes after the debate ends open
microphone
look out for the link and that's right
folks no matter what position you take
on any topic on this channel if you have
an after show
we are willing to link it in the
description though we appreciate it
it'll help us out we can get that link
in the description if you get it to us
before the debate starts which
john did so that's in the description he
also says
don't miss the after show which starts
five minutes after the debate ends
open mic discussion and he says question
for john
signal theory requires a completed
communication system
as its starting assumption yes or no
no it does not gotcha thank you very
much
yeah yeah so cues evolve into
signals so as a signal is an actual
signal and symbol are
pretty much the same thing you can
actually have signals that aren't
completely symbolic like uh you have the
let me just give tangent here like the
the roar
of a um of a red deer is a
uh it's a it's considered a sine
type signal because it's an actual
demonstration of how big it is the the
the tone that it can hit
depends on how how what size it is so
it's actually it's a sign
um rather than a or i can't remember
what they call it i think it's they call
it a sign
rather than a symbol but you get
you get the evolution of signals
these from q's so things start out as
queues uh and like like i talked about
with it with the bacteria
it starts out by one bacteria being able
to detect
the feces of a different bacteria the
waste product of a different bacteria
and then it responds in a way that
actually benefits both
the individuals and then the second
individual will eventually evolve
a way to magnify what used to be a cue
and once a cue is magnified actively
magnified by this sender
it's considered a symbol and you have a
communication system a true
communication system whereas before all
you had is a cue detection system
so gotcha thank you very much and next
question
comes in from dearest friend
mark reed says john what happens when
there
is an error in dna quote unquote code
versus computer quote unquote code
can the computer code function with
errors
well in this case with character
encoding errors
um you're gonna have so
if you were to change again we're
talking about the code we're not talking
about a specific sequence of rna we're
talking about the way that
the ribosome interprets a sequence in
the
in the rna so if you were to
um change the code
of a computer if you were to put in the
wrong code in a computer so if you were
to put in
if you have a computer that's designed
to read ascii code and you feed it boto
code instead
it's going to spit out gibberish and the
same thing with uh
with the genetic code if you take like
so our mitochondria use a slightly
slightly different code than our nuclear
genes do and if you put in a nuclear
gene into the mitochondria
it actually spits out it mostly reads it
correctly but it spits out some
gibberish it does some things wrong
so um that's what we're talking about if
when
if the the code
is if there's if there's error in the
code it's gonna
it's gonna spit out an error but if
you're talking about just a mutation
will a mutation in a gene cause
a catastrophic error in a protein that
depends
um it depends on how big the mutation is
it depends on
whether or not that mutation ends up
really being beneficial
or negative um so there's lots of
different
there's lots of different things that
can happen there thanks so much
and next one just came in this is a
brand new super chat from
logical plausible probable says for john
please come to
my after show i think you're missing the
point being made in relation to
the interpretation so don't know what he
means
this is over my head outside of my
specialty but you were invited over
there if you'd like john
and thank you very much for your
question this one coming in
two seconds loading up noah winslow
appreciate your questions said can we
get a definition of code i think you
guys have pretty much hashed that out
uh no let's say so that was an early
question by the way that's why they
asked
awesome ai360 says is
any chemical reaction a code
no you need to have a sender and
receiver
and for it for there to be a code
you got it i think yeah you bet and
thank you
very much gentlemen it's been a true
pleasure want to give you guys a couple
of updates out there thanks everybody
for your questions we appreciate them
and remember our guests are linked in
the description so hey
well check those links out and also i
don't know if i'd mention this
if you have if it's the first time
you've been here in a while we're
excited that we are
on twitch and we are at affiliate status
which is cool so dave langer thanks for
helping us
do that and so if you enjoy watching us
if you enjoy twitch more than youtube
well then hey
that twitch link is linked at the top of
the chat so i want to say
one last thank you though john perry and
t jump it's been a true pleasure
thank you guys so much for being on here
with us yeah
it's fun yeah thanks for coming on
thanks for john for the presentation it
was a really good presentation and i do
agree with everything in it it was
really great science so yeah thanks
again thanks
one sec you guys so sorry it's just that
it is dr cygar
this is kind of his wheelhouse so he's a
biologist john if you hadn't met him
uh he said great job john really
important to separate the two arguments
and stop denying science so it sounds
like you got a fan there john so thank
you very much
dr seigar we appreciate that and so with
that folks we hope you keep sifting out
the reasonable from the unreasonable we
appreciate you
and i'll be back in just a moment with a
post credit scene to give you updates
on new debates coming up so thanks so
much everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're dancing in the street
there's nothing left to eat
we're on our winning streak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen stoked that was an
epic one i hope you enjoyed that one as
much as i did
really fun i was like this is a fun one
i really i knew it was going to be fun
it was even more fun than i thought it
was going to be tremendous
want to let you know folks stuff coming
up we are really excited
i got to tell you this weekend in fact
is going to be
jam-packed with debates we have a triple
header this coming saturday you guys
it's gonna be
massive and these aren't just like oh
you got like some
decent debates huh no we've got like
seriously three big
epic debates that are going to be this
saturday so we hope you guys can tune in
for
at least one of those maybe two three
they're that good seriously that i think
you'd enjoy it jordan so sorry i missed
your question
uh let's see we just went off air i
think
right when your question came in sorry
man uh but we do
appreciate you asking your question and
thanks for just hanging out with us
and yeah you guys i will tell you
one is we have a newcomer
mark who wants to debate a
science-related topic in particular
you guessed it flat earth so that's
going to be late saturday night
but also other ones we have a
pretty you could say a juggernaut
tick-tock
influencer he has 659 000 followers he's
a very popular guy on tick tock
for his controversial videos he wears a
red
hat a red ball cap and uh
he will be debating another social media
influencer from a separate platform
she's on instagram and that will be on a
very controversial
topic i won't even say the word in the
stream but it's going to be a good one
folks and so we hope you can make it for
that
that's our that's our middle debate and
then right before that though we'll have
cosmic skeptic on
so he will be debating on veganism
against
tioga's favorite smoky saint so that
should be
a really good one folks we hope that you
make it for that and yeah i was like
i'm just seriously like wowed by the
fact that we've just got a lot of epic
debates coming up we've got a trifecta
debate
it's going to be coming up
monday so five days away that will have
christian versus yogi
hare krishna versus hair krishna i think
that's how you say it
very embarrassing i used to be more up
to date
then it will also have an atheist in the
discussion so you could say it'll be a
triple threat debate
that will be a fun one we also have
if i remember right samuel told me
that's the debate between
tom jump and samuel whether or not the
problem of evil disproves god
so that should be a juicy one that'll be
in person folks
that'll be on saturday february 5th
streamed live live show guys you better
tune in
this one's just you know open to the
public sometimes once in a while we get
a question on
how often are you going to do those
kickstarter type things to do those big
time debates
quarterly is the answer so we'll
probably do another one in april
would love if you guys have ideas on
like epic debates you'd just be like man
that would be awesome to see i'd be
stoked
to have a kickstarter for that let us
know we
really do want to have your feedback
your hand on the wheel
is important for us and so yeah some
announcements though
we have a lot of cool stuff first we are
on teespring
see this epic t-shirt no it's that
direction see that epic t-shirt like
right over there
just past cosmic skeptic toward the
corner
that shirt is on our teespring as well
as others
and mugs you can't go wrong with a mug
a modern day to bait mug and so just
consider that if you love
sweet merch also you guys this is
actually really cool too
if you're on twitch and if you have
amazon prime
you may not know that you have an like a
free
subscription you can use on virtually
any twitch streamer
and so that is actually uh
basically what you can do is you can use
it on
any twitch streamer and
that has affiliate status or partner
status and
that helps us a lot because each time a
person does that like let's say we had
100 people who did it
out of 39 000 and
because there's probably at least out of
the 39 000 subs there's probably like
100
amazon prime members i don't know it's
probably a lot more but
if we had just 100 though that used
their free twitch prime
sub on modern day debate that would get
us an extra 250
a month which really does seriously
that helps us a lot in terms of getting
new events
live events so we're uh
flying for example samuel down to
georgia to debate t
jump in person that's going to be epic
and so yes
twitch is linked at the top of the chat
lilly aja thanks for your help all the
time you
seriously rock you're always super
supportive and we appreciate that
and
also really excited folks
this is another way in addition to your
free twitch sub by the way the free
twitch sub
there's like a way in which you've got
to do it um if you just like type into
google
how to use your free amazon prime twitch
sub
a link will come up and i can even do
that for you and put it in the chat
how to use your oh there it is so
i'm going to put this in the chat it'll
show you how you can actually use that
amazon prime
free twitch sub and if you don't use it
here's the trick
i mean it's not it makes no difference
in terms of your private
membership costs it just if you don't
use it it's kind of just you could say
goes to waste
each month because you can use it one
time each month
and you have to sign up or you could say
resubscribe
each time that you actually use it and
so
i would just encourage you hey it's like
pretty cool so i would highly encourage
you if you go to amazon twitch prime
which hold on i'm having a little
trouble getting this link
we might have to
okay you have to
link your twitch account to your amazon
prime account
that's how you do it and so
basically once you do i think it maybe
takes a day or
maybe it might be less for you but it
pretty quickly will show up
or it'll show that you have like a free
twitch prime
sub that you can use on whatever speaker
or i should say
streamer you want and also though want
to say
if you didn't know this is something i'm
pumped about
so we have an amazon affiliate link if
you let's say you're like hey
uh yeah i don't have a ton of cash but
you know i'd love to support the channel
and uh or maybe you're like i've got a
ton of cash but i'm not going to use it
on modern day debate
that's all right what you could do
though is not use any cash
you could either like i said use that
amazon twitch prime sub
another thing is at the bottom of your
screen
use our amazon link in the description
basically if you use our amazon portal
link you get into amazon using the link
that we have in the description
to get on amazon and you'll see it it's
like not too far down
into the description box three percent
of whatever you buy
will go to modern day debate so like you
know if you bought something
like 50 bucks it's like yeah it's not
much like a dollar fifty but
that can add up too so uh seriously
it's something that we want to use to
kind of boost the channel's
content frankly we're not too worried
about channel art as you can see i still
make the thumbnails myself
so they're not fancy but we do seriously
want to do a lot more in-person debates
especially this summer
and we definitely want to do like i said
going for new guests
some of them like you know if it's a new
york times best seller
those usually aren't cheap and so for
example bartiman and mark
michael shermer both of them
new york times bestsellers you know cost
a few bucks
but i think it's a great show people
enjoy net seven thanks for your super
chat your super sticker with a thumbs up
appreciate that friend and so yeah air
church has just subbed on twitch
come on folks who's next thanks i
appreciate that air
church seriously i really do that means
a lot i'm just super excited that
it's like yeah i think it's dave langer
dave yeah it was dave langer
we appreciate that dave langer helped
tokyo lloyd
saw your men you were mentioned in the
chat said is the debate over yes this is
the post-credits scene
this is kind of like at the end of was
it the first avengers no it couldn't
have been the first
no it might have been where they showed
thanos at the very end was that the
first one
anyway yes we are really excited so
thanks so much air church for using your
twitch prime sub for modern day debate
we really do appreciate that
luis guido says cosmic skeptic vegan
debate yes
i agree i'm pumped we're excited to have
alex back
alex is a really pleasant fellow i
really do appreciate he's
you know he's just he's calm i like that
he's calm
he never does any any sort of like name
calling or anything like that he's very
calm
and i would say a rigorous thinker he's
a he's a tough thinker i
and the last topic i'd want to debate
him on is veganism
so that should be a really fun one folks
but yeah other ones i've gotta like
let me show you this i know that it's
like obsessive and you're like james
please stop
you're embarrassing yourself but
bottom right of your screen is bigfoot
real i hope you guys are pumped for this
dr jeffrey meldrum seriously this guy's
in documentaries
he is i mean he's a by the way i mean
he's he's not just like an informal
researcher he's got his doctorate in
like hominid
basically foot movement or something to
the effect of like
how hominids became some hominids i
should i
know i should know this became upright
or bipedal
walking under two feet and so like he's
a true expert like a true scholar
and i'm telling you when i when i heard
him on the uh when i heard him
on the actual documentary
i was like man he's he's smart
and i thought so i was watching
i was i can't oh it was called unwanted
bigfoot i think that's what it was on
amazon
the amazon prime video and i listen and
i
i thought this guy's good like this
would be really interesting yeah i think
it's
lily aja says i can't wait for a bigfoot
debate i can't wait
either it's seriously it's gonna be so
fun
and i'm just excited that it's like it's
a topic that is genuinely fun where it's
like that's kind of interesting to think
about like what if
and you might so before i watched the
video i was kind of like
let's say my probability was i was like
um
maybe about 40 in terms of my credence
of a bigfoot
existing so in other words it's like uh
i think it's
not very likely after i watch this video
i was like i don't know
maybe maybe like 50 i'm kind of agnostic
on the bigfoot issue
i'm telling you you have to you have to
listen to this guy
he's going to be debating a newcomer
named maddie she's a phd student
so you know so clearly she's intelligent
and
she is in meteorology that's her
specialty so she is at a small document
a small disadvantage because that's not
her specialty
and that makes a difference you know
having it be your specialty and
especially
dr meldrum you're seeing in the picture
there holding the foot cast or the uh
imprint uh the the footprint cast in his
hands there
he's also probably got a decade or two
of
research on the topic so he's she's got
her work cut out for her but i i'm
confident
she'll she'll make it an interesting
discussion so she'll give a
have some awesome stuff to add and it's
just going to be great so it's uh
lily i just said where did you see the
documentary and what is it called it's
called
unwanted bigfoot i'm pretty sure that's
what it was i'll double check right now
let me see amazon
prime video and it's spelt
unwanted as in
it's u n w
o n t e d
bigfoot uh basically oh no it's un
unwanted sasquatch sorry that's
embarrassing
yeah it was so good it's amazon's saying
watch again like i might
maybe tonight i don't know you'd have a
watch party lily yaja yeah so
but yeah it's it's seriously i was like
that is
well done it's got a 173 ratings too
because you might be thinking well yeah
but did the person who made the
documentary
did he or her and their few friends go
and just give it like some
super positive reviews like no i've got
173
that'd be a long time to make that many
fake reviews like it's
it's a quality show to watch i i do
recommend it
and so yeah yeah yeah air church says
james a bigfoot ist
not yet but maybe maybe someday i don't
know i'm like
i'm very much on the base and i gotta be
honest there's a part of me so yeah
um the purple owl thanks for your uh
input says
and thanks for hanging out with us too
said bigfoot is a cryptid based
on gigantopithecus and that is one of
the theories that dr meldrum says is
that gigantopithecus is basically it's
something
it's almost like imagine an orangutan
but nine feet tall
that's kind of the idea here is he says
hey
that is a plausible candidate that
that's this is something from the
i think you would say that would be the
ape family would it be
is orangutang and ape i don't know i
don't think
but lily i just says i don't think i've
ever seen a debate on bigfoot you're
right about that that i thought that was
going to make it fun and new too because
it's like that's pretty cool
and uh lilia just said where'd you see
the doc oh we got that
i'm slow here i like hanging out with
you guys just
taking it easy in the chat sunflower
appreciate your positive
support says bigfoot debate is going to
be absolutely epic long live modern day
debate appreciate that friend
and
a good theory says just tuning in when
will dr meldrum be on
it's this 23rd
let me check just to be sure yeah it's
the 23rd it's 10 days away from now
i'm telling you it's gonna be good mark
oh yeah i should have just typed it into
the chat
thank you i'm gonna pin mark
reads uh he spelled it out with the name
of the
documentary on amazon to check out that
dr meldrum is in
is unwanted sasquatch and the unwanted
or i should say unwanted it's it's not
an a
it's a an o there and then
master optics says nessie is cooler we
might if we can find somebody who's i i
the thing is i wanted to be someone in
uh like i'm sure there are intelligent
people out there obviously
that believe in nessie like i'm not
saying there aren't what i'm saying is
like once we find a good defender
because that's the thing is it's like
yeah i mean we could bring on like you
know uh
like uh like
nephilimfree's uncle or something to
defend
nessie but it's like i don't know like
are they gonna do a
like a strong are they gonna put a
strong case forward i don't know maybe
but yes as you've heard nephilimfree and
i had a fight
over this weekend i got nothing against
him but
i don't know hey that's all right we
hope he's doing well we don't hold
grudges here folks
and you know that's the thing i always
say if we can do
my philosophy is i want to treat other
people kindly but i want to have such
thick skin that people can just talk
smack
and you know whatever you know like we
got some haters
you know people sometimes you know say
oh james you think there's
you think there's a hater under every
rock i say
i don't think there's a hater under
every rock i think there's two haters
under every rock we've got some haters
you know folks it's funny that
but yeah so it's like but i always say
hey
we got way more lovers by the way and i
love you guys i appreciate you guys
always being positive
you guys make it absolutely worth it but
yeah i always my philosophy is i want to
be as kind as i can to others
and i'm not good at that i'm not i'm not
perfect at that i have
room to grow but i want to be
thick-skinned where it's like i don't
care you know do me a favor
don't harass the guests you want to
harass me hey knock yourself out
i kind of like it and nikolai
bibick said what like ness monster
yeah that would be cool but like i said
i'm not gonna bring
like i said i'm not gonna have like
nephilimfree's uncle come on and like
debate
the existence of net you know nessie uh
it's gotta be somebody that
you know like would be like
you know like dr jeffrey meldrum is a
perfect example if it's something like
that in the eq
like in the different context of nessie
if there's a doctor meldrum for that
domain then
sure i i would actually for real host it
but frankly i don't know if there i mean
there's got to be somebody out there
i'll see if i can find somebody
crispr cas9 says and zero possibility
there is a species of large hominid ape
with metropolitan distribution with
stable populations and no concrete
evidence
absolutely impossible
juicy very strong opinion there
appreciate you sharing that friend
nikolai
bibik says james do you need more hands
available for work
in colorado i appreciate that
friend i'm all right oh you mean like
like the doctor at work i i mean if you
do it's very kind of you because
sometimes it's exhausting
so i seriously appreciate that that's
kind of you
and lily i just said when i was in high
school i had a t-shirt that said loch
ness
lives that's what makes you cool lily
yaja you know that
appreciate that but yeah really exciting
uh sj is in the house glad to see sj i
hope you're doing well
and so yes you guys i am seriously
pumped
oh and then you'll see on the screen
right now as well
we're excited about this sometimes
people are like hey i don't really want
to give through patreon
is there a way i think it was her name
was ms dollface
in the chat a debate or two ago she said
can i give another way like paypal
and i at the time paypal was not working
so i want to let you know
our paypal link which is in the
description box below
is linking or working
if you don't want to give to patreon
like let's say you're like ah man i just
don't want to do like a
monthly pledge where it keeps you know
if it's like let's say an auto pay kind
of thing
and you're like i don't i don't want to
do that i just prefer to like no
commitment
just a one-time gift like hey paypal is
a great way to do it
or maybe you're like hey you know i
don't like patreon because they've kind
of like been hard on some of my favorite
speakers in the past and they kicked
them off the platform
whatever it might be you might say i
don't want to give money to patreon well
hey
paypal is linked in the description if
you want to support us and we appreciate
that
as we you guys i told i was in an
interview yesterday on uh smokey had me
on his channel
and so basically uh
want to give a huge thanks by the way so
smokey signed up for the
kickstarter reward of doing like an
interview
and so i want to say thank you so much
smokey for doing that he helped fund the
last kickstarter by doing that
so we do appreciate that and uh
it came with like the reward you could
say was
that i would do an hour interview it was
a blast and
uh i was telling him though 2021 we're
going to try to take some big
risks positive risks calculated risks
so not silly risks i know the difference
trust me i've
taken too many but this one i'm telling
you folks
i am excited for this year it's going to
be epic and so
with that i don't want to stay here too
long one thing i've like realized is
that
a challenging thing is that if i'm doing
these streams after if i'm doing the
post-credits scene
i love hanging out with you guys love
giving you updates we have honestly
there's so many debates that are coming
up that are going to be epic
we're trying to get david benatar who is
an anti-natalist
that would be epic if we can get him
he's in he's at cape town down in south
africa he's a professor so
what we want to do though is we have a
lot of debates like that
and i realized though i was like oh if i
do these
impressive glad to see you thanks for
your smile and wave
is if if i do these post-credits scenes
it might
overlap with
other people's after shows so i don't
i'm like ooh
i don't want to do them too long i don't
i don't know if i should do them too
often i don't know but i do like hanging
out with you guys and it's fun to like
catch up
and just say hi and so i will say this
before i go
if there's something i can do to make
your day better and i'm serious about
this
my email is i'm open about it it's just
modern day debate
gmail if there's something i can do to
make your day better i really do
want to be here for you we appreciate
you this is like a community for me and
seriously this is like
maybe it's certainly one of the best if
not the best part of my day
i just love it it's seriously so fun and
it just
puts me in such a great mood to be with
you guys so really appreciate you guys
thanks so much just for hanging out with
you know the more the merrier you guys
make it great
and you guys are like the devoted like
super positive you know encouraging
positive awesome people that are just
really i love you guys seriously you
guys that hang out at the after shows
are like the most supportive i
appreciate you and there's a lot of
other
super supportive people that aren't able
to be here right now but
um i just do appreciate you guys are
super
super supportive and so yeah i'm i'm
excited though you guys
i don't know if i ever told you this
story okay this is like the
third goodbye but
one of the reasons that i wanted to do
this channel was because in some places
sometimes in academia not all but some
some professors or people in academia
don't want to have
debates on controversial topics they
don't want certain controversial
speakers
and for me i said that's not what we
want we want to have a truly open
platform
controversial topics included and
one professor even in my own department
she tried to get the
channel in trouble no joke she reported
it to the ch the chair of the department
i don't know if i ever told you guys
that
um but i when that happened i was like
wow geez like
these people really not have that much
time on their hands or like looking at
their like the grad students
hobbies uh but yeah the point is and
that's like a very small amount of
people so
uh but yeah like like i said you know
i don't think there's a hater under
every rock i think there's two haters
under every rock okay
but nonetheless we're going to triumph
folks we have huge plans and that's the
trick
if you want to do something special i
mean
you've got to you've got to do something
to you know you got to stir the pot a
little bit anything
where you're trying to do something big
or exciting or you're trying to
just speak your own truth into existence
even
you're going to get haters that show up
this is the way it is so they don't
scare us
we are excited about the future we're
gonna do big things folks
believe me ashley thompson says that's
disgusting
i agree sj and i've heard of like weird
stuff that people have done
i heard of like a person who tried to
like
email your work workplace sj um
and try to get you in trouble it was
like some sort of a person who wasn't
even part of the university
and i was like jeez you guys like
who yeah it's so creepy and weird it's
like seriously
who even has that much time to where
you're like
don't you have other like don't you have
things to do in your life than to
try to try to email someone's work and
try to dox them about you know they say
this or their this their
they're they're radical is that fun you
know the funny thing is some people say
i'm like a radical about
like free speech or something and it's
like i'm
i'm like actually i would say
i do believe it's valuable at the same
time
there are a lot of topics we've never
done that are like way more
naughty according to youtube and so i
was like it's like we're still
pretty tame i think we're still pretty
family friendly and
mostly the reason to be honest we don't
want to saw off the branch we're
sitting on as a channel and so anyway
i'm babbling but tell me you guys
are you doing well jordan stripper
licker mark reed sj
perfect one moshi m
james w um
are you guys doing well i hope you're
doing well and so
really do appreciate the feedback on the
podcast and the
youtube channel but yes we're on
podcasts so if you enjoy
podcast folks you can always watch us
on podcast and yeah air church is
absolutely right i appreciate you saying
that said
awesome or kudos to the awesome
moderator team
that's so true it's so true you guys
mods you do a great job we really
appreciate you guys always
trying to sniff out and get rid of any
of the hate speech like we don't want
any of that
and so we appreciate you guys doing a
great job of that and
yeah but yeah crispr cas9 says
you're asking 138 people watching you at
9 50 pm if people have enough
free time to send an email yeah but
trust me you wouldn't do that
crispr were you the one that emailed
sj's job i'm just kidding i'm kidding
i was like uh but yeah no use
you guys are doing well the thing is
what we're all doing right now is
unwinding
um i personally wouldn't see it as like
unwinding like send people's like
employers email but anyway
the point is this want to say thank you
guys appreciate you
jg said did we answer the question is
dna code
well jg you'll have to ask the rest of
the chat i cannot say
but we really do appreciate you
so thank you very much for supporting
the podcast thank you so much
for always tuning in and yeah we
appreciate you guys we hope you have a
great rest of your day or night
depending on where you are keeps lifting
out the reasonable
from the unreasonable folks take care
yeah look at that bigfoot
is that i mean i'm sorry this thumbnail
i just i'm in love with it
it's fun it's so it's just bigfoot it's
a fun it's a fun topic
all right but seriously now i'm really
going to go this time it's like was it
tough the other day or somebody in the
live chat was like no
you say goodbye it's true it's hard to
say goodbye to you guys because i do
appreciate you i do love you guys
thank you guys so much and so with that
keep sifting out the reasonable from the
unreasonable
we'll be back on friday night
i can't remember it uh i know what it's
going to be good
let me think about this
you guys can't hear it where you are but
i hear the weirdest sound
and i even feel a tremble in the
building but i can't tell what it is
no idea i'll be all right but yeah so
yes
thank you guys it's always fun i hate to
think it's hazing goodbye i hate saying
goodbye you guys are great
have a tremendous night thank you so
much it's honestly it's going to be
amazing you guys i'm excited about 2021
so thanks for all your support
keep zipping out the reasonable from the
unreasonable take care
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're yeah in the street
there's nothing left to eat
we're on our winning streak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's time to pay
[Music]
explosions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]